[Musique]
je pensait sûrement pas à ses rangs
derrière je pense que je pense qu il
m'arriverait sur le rhin
[Musique]
c il était très violent garçons pas de
moteur nous on parle pas discute pas
y en a qui m'a attrapé il m'a évidemment
il est assez baraqué une amie m'a
attrapé les bras et
batman je tremblais pendant 20 minutes
j'ai pas tellement compris ce qui
m'était arrivé
[Musique]
ça m'est arrivé trois fois en tout la
première fois et à deux trois ans
c'était justin case de hoffman et pris
la fois d'après c'était un blouson comme
ça la fois la presse était un autre deux
ans encore plus gros et
voilà quoi
[Musique]
un camp de la convoitise le blouson
chevignon bat tous les records le
perfecto vous transforme en cible
jusqu'aux chaussures qui ne sont pas
épargnés attention weston au nike ou
reebok
pour les racketter comme pour les
racketteurs c'est la marque qui compte
et lycéens le savent bien pour assurer
2010 il faut savoir prendre quelques
risques
son manteau là et coûte plus cher que
mon blouson et a certainement plus de
chances que je me fasse voler mon
blouson noir vont se réveiller un peu
comme lui
et puis bon j'ai eu des problèmes aussi
et ben on va j'ai pensé que c'était
peut-être plus raisonnable de ne pas
s'habiller un peu avec le look rappeur
qui sont surtout recherché par parler
des players et pour pas se faire
dépouiller faut plutôt rester dans la
norme n'est pas s'habiller
excentriquement des parents ont dit oui
tu devrais de t'habiller un peu moins
provoquant parce que c'est assez
provocant ac et et moi j'ai dit non
justement je vais pas j'ai pas
m'habiller comme un clochard pour
pour leur faire plaisir si tu t'habilles
avec avec des affaires qui coûte assez
cher on te dira toujours assez bien
un drap d'une autre façon que si tu
t'amènes
cette semaine a mis fin de façon d'un
gars
faites
ça valorise la personne c'est une façon
de se valoriser
c'est sûr que si moi je serai du côté
des zonards je verrai
un petit bout en train de porter des
affaires à trois mille balles et
chaussures 2000 balle c'est sûr que
sûr que ça me donnera envie de d'aller
lui prendre justement
racketter ce n'est pas cédé à une
pulsion le désir de posséder s'organise
dans les banlieues du rmi les gosses
forme de véritables mafias ils sont 15
ans en moyenne et n'hésite pas à
descendre faire des rêves dans les beaux
quartiers pour s'amuser
ceux qui sont passés à l'acte se promène
sur les chemins de la délinquance comme
dans un jeu ils n'ont pas l'impression
de nuire c'est la loi de la rue qui
commande
quand par exemple le mec est bien sapés
et quand ils achètent des trucs voit
qu'on le regarde et qu'on n'a pas
d'argent ça fait c'est à dire
qu'on y va comme ça on a vraiment envie
de le recruter quoi c'est à dire
vous le ca fars
ce que nous on veut les mêmes mois mais
franchement quand je vois des petits
copains ça fait pitié mais je suis
obligé je pas pourquoi j'ai oublié quand
je vois mais quand on est en train de
dépouiller et moi si je fais rien et
vont me traiter de tels achats bouffon
ou est ce que je veux dire alors je suis
obligé de me fait pitié le mec quand je
parle c'est à dire quand je pars quand
je reviens chez moi je suis obligé de
penser à ça j'aimais pas vraiment les
bâtonnets mais les vêtements je l'aimé
pas je sais pas j'aime pas me mettre les
vêtements des autres mais j'ai bon c'est
à dire et quand j'ai à quelque chose je
vois direct et je me fais assez de fric
et des poêles manche et des baskets si
je veux je fais pas mes jambes j'ai
envie de faire
comme ça et je peux pas rester dans la
cité chiffres je bouge c'est comme ça
c'est tout le temps moi j'ai toujours
marché comme ça au moins c'est m'arrive
un truc un travail bien
d'avoir là j'essaie de me calmer parce
qu'avec la police tout ça ça va pas en
ce moment mes parents il commence alors
je vais me calmer mais moi je veux dire
18 ans j'arrête tout tout au tout
pas si j'ai des enfants tous âges pas
envie de qui deviennent comme moi autant
profiter maintenant voilà le phénomène
du racket ne se cantonne pas à paris ou
à ses banlieues ici à royan l'histoire
d'anthony 13 ans et demi aurait pu très
mal tourner
il a voulu mourir d'être racketté avant
de prendre des barbituriques
il écrivait
on me forçait à voler j'ai volé beaucoup
je n'ai même plus aucune raison de vivre
à quoi sert de vivre quand on a des
soucis ou canton ancré aux autres
anthony a été rackettés pendant un an et
demi pendant un an et demi il s'est muré
dans son silence ils avaient peur ils
avaient honte il ne s'est confié à
personne ni à sa mère ni à ses
professeurs ni à ses copains du jour au
lendemain ce bon élève plutôt gai est
devenu un tiers sont désespérés chez lui
on n'est pas riche et pour combler les
exigences du racketteurs tyrannique qui
lui flanquer des coûts ni il lui a fallu
voler
anthony a fini par craquer je les
trouvais en revenant de faire mes
courses
dans un état comateux je me demandais ce
qu'il avait fait ce qu'il avait pris et
sur la table de son bureau il avait
laissé une lettre effectivement où ils
disaient qu'ils voulaient mourir que on
le forçait à faire ces choses là et
qu'il pouvait plus supporter ils peuvent
plus supporter ce genre de de
compression de contraintes et il voulait
il voulait en finir parce que c'était un
problème pour tout le monde
après ce serait mieux pour lui c'était
mieux c'était la seule porte de sortie
qu'il avait trouvé
et puis on s'est retrouvé
à l'hôpital
complètement dépassés par ce juste cette
chose puis bon ça a été dur
mais il avait toujours pas parler là non
plus il a parlé l'après-midi dans
l'après-midi dans le courant de l'après
midi
toute la famille a été là qu'est ce
qu'il a dit à ce moment là et c'est pas
à moi que c'est adresser cet ac seraient
vus il a déclaré qu' il y avait à dire
qui toutes les semaines
exigeait de lui de l'argent et quand il
n'a pas d'argent des objets ce qui
pouvait ramener de la maison
éventuellement et comme le gamin
n'a pas voulu prendre quoi que ce soit à
la maison c'était c'était dans les
magasins que ça se passait
depuis cette histoire anthony a voulu
apprendre à se défendre il est devenu un
habitué des salles de boxe
pour anthony le sport c'est un peu une
façon de réparer ses blessures et de
sortir de son mutisme
c'est vrai que cette coalition familial
on l'a retrouvé un petit peu si on
voulait mais il ya encore des passages
difficiles et malheureusement j'ai peur
que ça ne tue crainte salon dure un
certain temps je vois qu'en fait il ya
pas qu anthony camargue et on y touche
marquée par sa non pourra pas oublier
c'est pas possible
pour vous la faire faudrait être plus
tôt accusé que victime
parce que
ils doivent se les accusés de se sentir
plus
salut marque moins que la victime
parce que ce que ce qu'avait le dessus
c'est
si cet effort pour ça ils doivent être
fort pour bien d'autres choses
je pense par moments
on se dit on est peut-être coupable de
ne pas l'avoir dit plus tôt
et puis la chine une sorte de monde
qui dura chute
brigade des mineurs de seine saint denis
ici on traite aussi bien les affaires de
raquette de prostitution enfantine que
de mauvais traitements avec gaël est
pourquoi
la délinquance des mineurs c'est le
quotidien d'isabelle et de bernard
depuis une dizaine d'années ils ont dû
croître le phénomène du racket la
routine aujourd'hui kg le racketteur en
flagrant délit le conduire en garde à
vue prévenir le parquet appelé les
parents
après le travail de bureau patrouilles
de surveillance pour isabelle et bernard
à bord d'un sous marin comme il
l'appelle dans leur jargon un camion
banalisée équipé d'une glace sans tain
il se poste à la sortie des collèges
pour observer sans être vu
hommes s'entendaient très bien
il a toujours eu en finale
mon isabelle tu vas prendre des photos
et je prends les bacs
il prend les jeunes hésitent à venir en
voir à venir raconter leur raquette je
crois qu'ils ont peur il ya toujours une
menace qui pèse
au dessus d'eux et ils ont peur surtout
que si on n'arrive pas à attraper
les racketteurs ce ces derniers se venge
prévenir pour guérir la police a mis en
place des programmes de prévention dans
les quartiers difficiles
sylvie 30 ans connaît le secteur comme
sa poche les enfants ont pris l'habitude
de la voir tous les jours à la sortie du
collège du coup ils hésitent moins à
venir se confier
je dis n'importe quel geste est
important pour ma
part en benoît 2 mètres 70
souvent c'est les parents qui se rende
compte de la disparition du buzzer ou la
disparition d'argent ou la disposition
des dettes des chaussures aux lendemains
qui arrivent et qui est agressive qui
est agacé qui viola qui était inquiet et
à force de le faire parler d'arriver à
comprendre que le problème c'est le
racket mer
je veux dire on a toujours affaire aux
parents ça se passait quand papa et
maman viennent avec la bande am on me
parle pas à ne pas passer la mer qui
feinte la passe et de la demande aussi
le faire tout à la place de la mode donc
on n'a pas vraiment on sait pas
exactement ce qui se passe bien entre ce
fait comment dire ça fait désordre
d'aller voir la police car il essaie de
régler beaucoup de leurs affaires en
trop
le racket pour un chef d'établissement
aussi ça fait désordre la réputation du
lycée ou du collège risque d'en souffrir
ou préfèrent voilée ce genre de violence
sous un silence prudent
journée particulière pour les élèves de
4e du collège jean jaurès
les policiers sont là en service
commandé
laurence l'assistante sociale du collège
les a appelés pour briser le tabou du
racket
[Musique]
le débat démarre difficilement la peur
du gendarme n'incite pas les jeunes au
dialogue là on a envie d'aborder ce
matin à thèmes qui touchent tous deux
prêts qui touche beaucoup d'adolescents
qui le thème du racket
parce que c'est quelque chose que l'on
vit tous au quotidien dans tout
établissement scolaire et dans toutes
citées dans tout environnement parce que
c'est lié à l'adolescent proprement dit
je pense que chacun d'entre vous vous
l'avez vécue si ce n'est personnellement
en tout cas au travers de vos camarades
première étape pour briser la glace un
petit film amateur dont les enfants
d'une association de boudy sont les
auteurs
c'est un cinéma vérité que les enfants
connaissent bien qu'ils aient été
rackettés ou peut être même un
racketteur monal tu l'as mis à
sac selon coupe les oreilles d'accord
quant au maire il
oui oui comment vous le flic d'accord
n'est pas là pour savoir qui rackettent
on s'en fiche de ce soir c'est pas le
poids ce qu'ils rackettent je pense de
l'amdes soumettront après je pense que
c'est important ils menacent aussi et
surtout ne va pas te plaindre surtout ne
va pas te plaindre car si tu vas plein
des conséquences restent encore pire
alors tu nous as mais ce qu'on te
demande et puis tu te tais surtout un
vous insistez ce qu'ils rackettent si
vous gagnez ainsi beaucoup là dessus je
pense mais alors moi j'aimerais bien que
ceux qui parlent jamais qu'ils n'en
parlent pas qu'ils sont inquiétés qui
refuse d'en parler pourquoi pourquoi ce
refus des autres dialogues pourquoi ce
silence cette loi du silence du ray par
exemple il va aller dire à ses parents
je me suis fait racketter et pendant qu
est-ce qui vous faire du petit bois ils
vont aller voir le garçon naît le sahara
après il j'assure frappé le lendemain
voilà vous être affecté quelque
étreindre acquitté ça se passe
bien y penser deux ans pour vol et on
qualifie le vol en france au delà de ce
qui est réellement passé c'est à dire si
le cil racketteurs a utilisé une arme
genre bombe lacrymo plus tôt et serra
pour impressionner le le le racketter
peur
comment va sa fin la violence
et oui le racket c'est un vol avec
violence les policiers n'ont rien appris
à ses élèves de 4e comme si le vol et la
violence faisait désormais partie de
leur quotidien une seconde langue au
delà de la fiction et de la mise en
scène de ces jeux de rôle il y à la
réalité du racket qui elle n'est pas un
jeu d'enfant
tout au long de cette matinée un peu
particulière la peur du gendarme s'est
estompée demain peut-être qu'un tel
débat en versera cette logique infernale
qui fait du racket la norme et du
représentant de la loi un épouvantail
[Musique]